I'm very interested in this idea of
inevitability of globalization you
touched on earlier you said that you
know that this is the direction that
we're moving in in your speeches as well
from what I've read it seems like there
are two sort of major strands of
thinking on this idea of inevitability
of globalization on the one hand is this
idea of technological determinism that's
sort of the technologies that we've
created are pushing us sort of whether
we like it or not into this into this
new world the other perspective though
is that globalization is the direct
result of actions by government leaders
and also by people thus you know new
representative governments that allow
for the the you know the breaking down
of borders and boundaries economic and
otherwise I think it's a pretty
interesting dichotomy do these two
perspectives because the second
perspective means that it's also that
you know that people can reverse
globalization as well if they see that
it's not working in their best interest
so my question to you is you know how do
you sort of view this concept of
inevitability of globalization given the
ebbs and flows that we've had in this
process not just in the last century but
you know even if you look at 900 in a
long sort of span of history and given
all the end are the threats of terrorism
and what we see today and some would
argue the over interconnection of
economies are they is it a threat for
this sort of interconnection and in the
future yeah well I think and how would I
put this I mean this is sounds like a an
oxymoron but I would say that I would
say the globalization is inevitable
unless someone really moves in to stop
it
in other words I think there is a
process of globalization the chief
characteristic of which is fast-moving
change that pushes people together right
that's that's because that's just the
way that's what Travel is doing and
communication is doing and I just think
that is principally driven by but by
people and governments in my experience
are usually responding to that wish for
the cross-border trade and travel and
intercourse between different peoples
now that is not so I think left to
itself it's that that's what will happen
but I think you're right that it is
possible to be able to mobilize people
against it you know that's why in Europe
today I mean you would you would winner
or not that you would win but you would
definitely have a fighting chance of
winning any election on immigration
because it's a way of people standing up
and saying I want this process to stop
yeah why I remember living in this
neighborhood when there weren't these
different people here and now they are
and I feel my life has been taken from
me and you guys you politicians and the
first politician the stands up and says
it's time we reclaimed this territory
for ourselves you know they get a lot of
applause and a lot of votes so I think
it's possible and it's possible then the
religious culture also to faith to play
a part and pulling people away from that
but I kind of might my belief in the end
is that we can get there with
globalization proceeding but with some
values and some sense of justice and
equity underpinning it or we can get
there having gone through decades of
fighting and shouting and pulling apart
but actually we will probably end up
you know unless there is something
utterly cataclysmic in the world with it
still moving forward because I just
think it's the it's the way that it is
and it's you see the other thing that's
interesting is to try and show people
how it is an enriching experience you
know to go and for this this this
intercultural and actually interfaith
encounter I mean it's I find it
fascinating you know I think it's
something that people in the end would
welcome the opportunity to do that's why
I think this process in a sense that the
impulses are inevitable I guess it's
always possible though that you could
have someone who who tries to stop it
and you're right also incidentally in
that they're very interconnectedness
this is why we've got to try and resolve
these questions makes it vulnerable you
know the reason the economic system the
world is vulnerable today is it operates
through confidence globally
you know that's but would we prefer to
be without it no probably